i'm like a secret redneck yeah
whatever we do the south goes way harder
just like all decadent as [ __ ] that like
you eat it and then it's just nap time
i'm really excited for sweet tea
because i feel like ladies like sweet
tea and i've always wanted to be a lady
oprah or
okra what's okra so this is okra dude
it's okay i thought it was an animal it
looks like a banana pepper what are they
called pepperonis why don't you like
open it it's so slimy it's disgusting
yeah
i love a good pickle
what's this a little peanut yeah a
little peanut little peanuts it looks
like a cartoon of like what a little
poop would look like doesn't it oh it's
slimy i don't like that as wet
it feels like a bean not salty
as [ __ ] though i like it a lot i'm
pleasantly surprised i'm not gonna lie
liver mush
it looks like burnt toast a weird
brownie that's what it feels like it
smells pretty good i'm not mad at it
maybe we'd be good with like ketchup or
like a sauce
yeah it's like a sandier
cousin of the hamburger i could see
myself cutting open one of these
biscuits putting it in there
can you give us like five minutes i just
want to finish eating
country ham country ham country ham
it's not your typical deli ham you see
in the supermarket this is like
ham you guys are on some next level [ __ ]
here it's like a hug from the lord it's
delicious
what would happen if i replaced my
morning coffee just with this gravy oh
here's something that tastes good i know
what we'll do we'll soak it in butter
and gravy oh you're a genius
oh it's a moon pie
yes oh my god
who needs some like something this big
there's like three cookies in one looks
like a s'mores on steroids um can i take
this with me it's probably the thickest
cookie i've ever had a lot to bite into
i could see like every
third grader in the south like just
having one of these in their lunch boxes
is this something where i'm like oh i
like this is this the best thing i've
ever eaten no but like i if you try to
take it away from me i would kill you i
think all southern food feels like it's
prepared with love i think there's
something to be said for this food in
moderation you're worried about your
argument california needs to step it up
i know we're like everything we're doing
is like how can we add kale to it [ __ ]
that give me the sugar ham yeah i think
southern food makes you happy while you
eat it and then right afterwards you're
like all right nap time
and then you're happy while you nap
when you wake up and you're cranky and
you just eat again you're happy